uh
[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here so
kick
talk that's what just happened to the
macbook air
not tick tock not the short form video
website but two years ago we had a thin
wedge-shaped intel powered macbook air
super popular laptop but that was also
the beginning of the apple silicon
transition and that transition to
designing their own silicon would mean
they could unlock levels of optimization
and streamlining that were never before
possible when using an off-the-shelf
chip from intel so first they replaced
the intel chip with an m1 chip in the
wedge-shaped macbook air pick
now they've redesigned the entire
computer around apple silken with m2
talk so theoretically this is more than
just a refresh this is our first look at
what's possible with apple in a thin and
light form factor now that they finally
design the silicon and everything around
it
and it's also
deceivingly expensive but we'll get to
that in a second so with apple's most
popular mac i fully expect a level of if
it ain't broke don't fix it but to their
credit they have changed and updated
mostly everything about this design and
for the better the wedge shape used to
taper to appear and feel thinner at the
edges but now the whole thing is flat
it's 11 millimeters all the way across
which is actually thinner overall and i
really like it this way this is one of
those shapes that you just feel like you
can pick up and take everywhere truly
ultra portable they've thinned out the
bezels around the new display which let
them bump it up a bit to 13.6 inches
diagonally there's a notch in the top
middle which has become a part of
apple's design language at this point
but that quickly fades away to invisible
when you're actually using a laptop and
it's housing a new 1080p webcam that
looks
fine i mean for sure better than the old
one also the display is way better it
has a higher 500 nit max brightness and
a lower minimum brightness for working
in dim environments which i actually
found really useful when publishing the
nothing phone review at five o'clock in
the morning here they also added magsafe
plus the color matching braided cable
which is a nice touch by the way they do
include the midnight colored stickers
with the midnight colored laptop that's
another nice touch but the magsafe
charger also just means you freed up
another usb type-c port and you also get
that fast charging at up to 67 watts
which is nice because the battery again
makes this a very long lasting laptop
i'll still say the m2 macbook pro which
is thicker is still going to be an
overall battery champ but i mean
the 15 hours of claimed web browsing
translated for me to an entire work day
of use with 20 plus percent left it was
awesome and if i had several light days
in a row with it i didn't even really
think about charging it's great it's not
perfect though i do still wish that
they'd put usb type c on both sides but
as of right now it's two usb type-c
thunderbolt 3 on the left headphone jack
on the right and so it only supports one
external monitor and if you do have an
external monitor it'll probably have to
be to the left and then when i first got
hands-on with this thing i was very
curious about the speakers because as
you can see they are pretty much
invisible unless you know where to look
but they are right up in the hinge of
this laptop so i was curious if they'd
be any good and i guess i shouldn't be
surprised but turns out they sound
really good they sound great not as much
bass and and thump as the bigger laptops
like the macbook pros but still very
very loud and more than enough for media
consumption that type of thing music
watching videos all that sort of stuff
the one thing that turns out to be a
downer here as much as i
wanted to love it is uh this new color
so the m2 macbook air now comes in
silver and space gray like before then
there's a new starlight color which is a
very
faded gold and then this which is
midnight midnight is a very very dark
blue and it absolutely changes how much
blue it shows based on the environment
you're in like if the light hits it just
right it can look like a blue laptop but
in some environments it just looks like
a matte black laptop which i think is
sick but we were right in the first
impressions this one is an absolute
fingerprint magnet the instant you start
using it and it's impossible to keep
clean but then on top of that there are
some durability concerns the normal wear
and tear on the trackpad area seems fine
and i've only had this for a week so i
can't really test a long time use but
what we saw on the review unit that i
had a couple weeks ago or the first
impressions unit was around those ports
the usb-c port and magsafe ports if you
miss plugging it in enough times you're
gonna scratch the paint and it'll be
most noticeable on this dark laptop
because it has silver underneath so i
guess there's three solutions one uh
don't get this color
two if you do get this color maybe
protect it with a case or a dbrand skin
that's my personal preference there's
lots of great dbrand skins to make the
the back of the laptop especially not
look so ridiculous
or three
um
take really really good care of it but
overall though the new design i like it
a lot it is remarkably thin it's not the
thinnest and lightest laptop in the
world but it's one of those like i could
carry it everywhere type things i love
using it every day it makes me kind of
jealous because i in my normal workflow
regularly do video editing on a laptop
now so i carry around this huge 16-inch
laptop but yeah if i didn't have to do
that i would love to carry this around
so it's fantastic but speaking of
workflow and horsepower we've now also
seen already what the new m2 chip inside
this thing is truly capable of because
we also took a look at the m2 macbook
pro and we love it we love the cpu
improvement the gpu improvement is even
more substantial and the new higher end
media engine coming down to m2 is
awesome for video workflows especially
in apple's optimized apps it's just
better than m1 across the board but now
the most popular thing that everyone's
been wondering that the most common
question i got when i asked on twitter
instagram i asked you guys what you want
to know about this laptop is what's the
difference in performance between the m2
chip and a fan cooled system like the m2
macbook pro and in the fanless system
that is the macbook air because in the
short bursty stuff it keeps up with the
macbook pro just fine they are very
similar in performance with short
repetitive quick stuff up to a couple
minutes but at some point with a
sustained workload
this laptop is going to get so hot
without a fan that it has to throttle to
not overheat and this one with a fan
will keep going at its normal
performance
where is that point and so i tried it
with some benchmarks i've done it with
some real world applications and it
turns out that that point is somewhere
around
five minutes
seems pretty short but when you think
about it that's a lot of sustained load
so that's not photo editing that's not
web browsing or even like coding or or
short bursty like benchmark stuff a two
minute benchmark won't show that
difference here i'm talking about like
video editing or long renders when you
have background rendering on for 5 10 15
minutes in a row gaming even things that
light up all of the cores all at once
for several minutes in a row sustained
and that is where the macbook air really
gets tested i noticed it actually heats
up quite a bit right in the middle so if
your laptop's on your bare legs on your
lap you're gonna feel that but yeah
that's where you hit the difference
between the m2 macbook pro and the m2
macbook air but this is also kind of
hilarious and impressive to me because
we can't forget what this machine
actually is which is
it's a macbook air it's the baseline
it's the level of their laptop lineup so
the fact that we're considering if it
can handle maybe four streams of 4k
video editing at once or like big long
renders or projects over a certain size
is uh kind of amazing like i saw brian
tong shout out to him and his videos he
did a giant 45 minute 20 video track 20
audio track 4k export in premiere to
really see the difference between the
macbook air and the macbook pro by the
way the difference was like 10 minutes
so thank you for going through that for
us brian uh but yeah that's incredible
because that's clearly not what this
machine is really for it's for the
everyday use of uh
30 chrome tabs or
15 apps open at once but not really
rendering or doing any sustained loads
just like a bunch of normal stuff going
on so basically the one thing going
against this macbook air for me
is the price
okay so this laptop starts at 11.99 so
1200
uh which is already 200 more than the m1
macbook air is which stays in the lineup
by the way it was a pretty good laptop
when it came out still is that's a
thousand so this is 1200
but the baseline version also has the
same
ssd issue
that the baseline m2 macbook pro had
meaning the 256gb version which uses a
single ssd module instead of two smaller
ones is significantly slower than the
rest of the lineup literally half the
speed and that's not insignificant
remember the base version also has just
eight gigs of memory right and the m2
system on a chip means that shared
memory is for the entire system so if
you're doing enough you can actually
fill up that memory pretty quickly which
is when it starts to swap over and use
the ssd and when that happens
things actually start to feel slower on
this base model so it costs another 200
bucks to upgrade it to 512 gigs that's
the version i've been testing and that's
what it should have started at in the
first place now you're sitting at 1400
bucks and 1400 bucks is not the same
like super easy magical like thousand
dollar price point like we had with the
last generation that's a lot more so
here's how i think about this if you are
someone who's actually considering
buying the new macbook air i would just
consider this a 1500 laptop any less if
you don't want to spend that much and
you probably should be looking at the m1
macbook air that's still a thousand
dollars still in the lineup still a
great laptop but if you're looking
higher up for certain reasons just know
that the 14 inch macbook pro is just
sitting right there waiting for you at
two thousand dollars obviously this is
very strategic by apple and the way
they've priced all this is
well thought out i guess you could say
but the point is if you're planning to
do a lot more of that creative stuff
higher-end workflows sustained loads uh
the 14-inch macbook pro is a way better
laptop like if i want to spec up this
macbook air up to a way where i think
it'll be very comfortable for a couple
of years doing this creative stuff so
you're going to add the 10 core gpu
you're going to go up to 2 terabytes of
storage you're going to max it out let's
say 24 gigs of memory which is the new
max for the m2 that's already over 2 000
and that'll be a really really nice
macbook air and a lot of people who get
it are going to love it but the 14 inch
macbook pro runs circles around this
laptop at the same price and it has a
way nicer screen for that creative stuff
it has ports for that creative stuff and
it has an sd card slot which is what
most of that creative stuff is going to
need if you're doing that so i would
suggest considering it so it's a little
bit deceivingly pricey but the sweet
spot for this macbook air is right
around fifteen hundred dollars and i
think if that's the one you're
considering that's the one you should go
with there's gonna be lots of people
around that spec that i think you're
gonna really love it but other than that
that's been my
review of the fingerprinties laptop
we've ever seen
aside from all the other matte black
laptops anyway that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace